انا شفت المنظر تبنجت هيك ثانيتين بعدين
رحت جريت عليها كل الناس شردت وانا رحت
عند امي لقيتها رافعه صباعها زي هيك
وبتتشال وهاي اللحظه وين راح انا مش عارف
ما حدش كان عارف وين
راح اشتقتلك كتير انت وجاز وبابا
وبستناك وبحبكم كثير
بستناكم محمد باسم ابن هاله عبد العاطي
اللي استشهدت في محيط ملعب فلسطين
بالفيديو اللي انتشر برصاصه غادره من
الاحتلال
الصهيوني بحيث انه هو قالنا انه نطلع
وارفع رايات بيضاء وحتم عادي احنا في
يوم 1111 تحصرنا
بالدبابات فقلنا بدنا نطلع كنا جهزنا
رايتنا البيضا قبل التحرك تقريبا كان 20
نفر بس في بيتنا هم احنا كنا كذا كذا
عائله في المنطقه كانت امي ماسكه ايد تيم
وطالعه فيه وانا كنت وراها بدينا نمشي صار
في صوت طخ في الشارع يعني اول ما بدينا
نبين في الشارع ودار خالتي بد اجوا ودار
اخوالي اجوا صار في صوت طخ لحتى الان عادي
يعني طخ على الحيطان كانوا مشينا هلقيت في
ناس بقولوا انه في جندي كان على الد بابا
ماشر لهم انهم يطلعوا لفوق اذا شفتوا
بالفيديو كل الناس طلعت لفوق انا في وقتها
قعدت انادي على امي اقول لها اطلعي تعالي
لهيك تعالي لهيك فجاه وقعت على الارض ق
هذا اللي انا شفت يمكن ما
استوعبت طبعا تيم كان في ايدها وشرد طلع
لفوق انا شفت المنظر تبنجت هيك ثانيتين
بعدين رحت اجريت عليها كل كل الناس شردت
وان رحت عند امي لقيتها رافعه اصباع زي
هيك وبتشاهد ما استحملت المنظر حاولت اني
اشيلها كان الحمل علي
ثقيل وبزعق ماحدش برد علي او مش شايف شي
كنت لحد ما اجا ابويا سندني في حملها
وجريت فيها لحد ما وصلت المفترج ابن جيران
ابو يزن حملها عني وجرت على الدار جراي
فتحت الباب دوب وصلت حاولوا يعملوا لها
اسعافات
اوليه كان يعني كانت الرصاصه كثير عامله
فتحه هالقد تقريبا كانت عند القلب
لفوق استهداف متعمد اه قناص يعني ما فيش
مرا كبيره وماشيه معها حفيدها ورافعين
رايات بيضا قبل ما نطلع بعش دقائق كانت
تقرا قران
وتسبح حتى يعني الشي الوحيد اللي
ظللي منها هي
سبحت هذا دائما انا حاملها
معي كانت تسبح
وتدعي تحكي ان عشنا فهنا من اهل الدنيا
وان متنا فاحنا شهداء هذه اخر الحاجات اخر
الكلمات اللي
حكتها